[Music]
hey
so he's coming in you can't see like
this
too much mass coming from this is more
like a stop hit
oh he's hitting it as he's coming in
not like
stop it
you should be taking too much impact
okay i'm not gonna pull the joke
take your camera
same concept he's coming in
the knot here
he hits the stop hit
[Music]
so same thing is not one and then here
he hits the jackpot yeah
and this just like the ski the ski
my center barely moves around the tip of
this ski
my target barely moves around the the
ball of the fist there
so not like this he's hitting
him
okay let me do the right cross
bone okay so key on these stop hits is
that you don't create these
big deviations okay so this
right cross i have to look at it i have
to look at it
not like this i have to look at it
head towards it look at it head towards
it
[Music]
and i have to read it i can't wait for
it to get
here i have to read it
okay let's go